This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Sophie.
And I'm Neil. Did you watch the Tour de France cycling race this summer Sophie?
No, I didn't. I'm not a cycling enthusiast, Neil, unlike you.
I was pretty exciting stuff. In fact, just thinking about it
makes me want to jump on my bike and ride off right now.
Don't go just yet because today's show is all about bicycles
and I've got a question for you. Who invented the first pneumatic or air-filled cycle tire in 1888?
Was it A John Boy Dunlop, B Charles Goodyear or C Harvey Samuel Firestone?
Well, I'm going to go for A John Boy Dunlop. Can I go now?
No, you can't. We'll find out later on in the show if you got the tire question right or not.
But first, I'd like you to tell us a bit about the history of the bike.
If you insist, well, before the modern bike was invented in 1885, people rode
bone shakers, high wheelers and even tricycles.
A tricycle is a three-wheeler bike that young children ride before they learn to balance
on a two-wheeler. But what's a bone shaker, Neil?
It was the first bike with pedals called a Velocipede by its manufacturers.
Others called it a bone shaker because its tires were made of iron,
so it was very uncomfortable to ride, especially over cobblestone streets.
It sounds awful. Now moving on, the bicycle started out as an expensive toy for the middle classes.
But when manufacturing costs dropped, they became a vehicle for social change.
By the late 19th century, bikes had become affordable for a large proportion of the population
and the technology had moved on, so they weren't so dangerous, also uncomfortable to ride.
And for the first time in history, people had the freedom to travel where they wanted,
when they wanted, including women. Let's hear more about women in cycling from Robert Penn,
UK author and lifelong cyclist.
In very practical terms, it had a very significant effect on what women wore in public.
And when they first rode bicycles, they were expected to ride in long ankle length skirts and
voluminous petticoats. And of course, that was entirely impractical. So they adopted what was
called rational dress. And rational dress was a better fitting jacket and pantaloon trousers,
which are cinched below their knee, which meant that nothing got caught in the chain.
And at first, there was massive public outrage. There were core cases about whether or not
women were allowed to be served in pubs wearing this sort of dress.
So women in the 19th century typically wore long skirts and voluminous or large petticoats.
A petticoat is a piece of clothing worn under a dress or skirt. But what does rational dress
mean exactly, Sophie? Rational here means logical. It wasn't logical to wear ankle length skirts
with voluminous petticoats on a bike. So women started wearing pantaloon trousers.
Pantaloon trousers were baggy, though they were cinched or gathered in below the knee,
so they wouldn't catch in the bicycle chain. But pantaloons for women still caused outrage
or shock and anger. Because although they were baggy, they were still trousers. And they didn't
go down to the ankle. So bikes played a part in women's struggle for emancipation or freedom.
But let's listen now to Robert Penn, who claims that it also played a role in our evolutionary history.
It's definitely sure that the gene pool in countries like Britain, because it meant that people
could go further than they ever had before in order to find a partner for life and to mate.
And so what started as a really fadish leisure pursuit within a decade of 1885,
the bicycle became the most popular form of transport on the planet, and it has been ever since.
What does shore up mean, Sophie? It means support. And gene pool here refers to the collection of
genes in a particular population. So when people travelled further to marry and have children,
they were making the gene pool bigger and healthier. And Robert Penn uses the word fadish. He says
cycling started as a fadish thing. A fad or fadish activity means an enthusiasm for something that
doesn't last very long. But your enthusiasm for cycling is not a fad. No, it isn't. Do you think
like-rowaring is a fad and we'll all go back to wearing pantaloons in the future, Sophie? No?
Not a good look. Okay, maybe it's time for the answer to today's quiz question.
I asked, who invented the first cycle tire in 1888? Was it A, John Boyd Dunlop? B, Charles Goodier,
or C, Harvey Samuel Firestone? And I said John Boyd Dunlop, tell me I'm right. You are right.
Well done, Neil. Scottish inventor and veterinary surgeon John Boyd Dunlop developed the pneumatic
rubber tire. Although it was invented as an improvement on the bicycle, the pneumatic tire arrived on
the scene just in time to contribute to the success of the car. Now here are the words we heard
today. They are pneumatic, voluminous, petticoat, rational, pantaloon, cinched, outraged,
emancipation, shore up, gene pool, fad or fadish. Well that's the end of today's six-minute
English. Please join us again soon. And we're on social media too. Make sure to visit our profiles
on Facebook, Twitter, Instagram and YouTube. You can get on your bike now, Neil. Goodbye. Bye-bye.